Not Bad words.
No words are bad,
but some people start using them a lot
to hurt other people and then they
become bad.
It'd become a hard,
there's words that I love that I can't
use because other people use them wrong
to hurt other people.
Like the word cons is a beautiful word
to me.
Beauty forward and I don't,
I mean aesthetically it has like
chocolate and around on the ends.
I just liked,
I just liked the way it sounds and I
don't use it as an insight.
I'm alone in my laundry.
I'm like tones.
Okay.
Words hold a lot of weight.
When you give a guy in particular swear
words,
while people may just consider them a
way to make something funny or to show
someone's,
Matt actually goes a lot deeper than
that.
I want to explore swear words,
see how they're used and how they reveal
a lot more than you may think.
That's awesome.
I want
to know where swearing came from.
One has to look no further than the word
itself.
The word swearing and cursing are
biblical in origin.
The first words that were taboo where
words that said the Lord's name in vain
way back in the day,
swearing on the Bible was a big deal
because people really thought perjury
undetected by the legal system would be
punished by an ease dropping and easily
offended God.
Do you swear to tell the truth,
the whole truth and nothing but
similarly a curse on someone was not
only serious but also deadly.
Nowadays our society has lessens the
power of those vulgarities and focused
more on the taboos of sex and bodily
functions.
She looked me in the eyes and said,
mom is making a pub salad and I need
some sets,
own dressing,
but I think
it's a common misconception to think
we've become completely desensitized
from swears in the 21st century.
Sure.
Plenty of movies swear like crazy,
but swear words still hold that element
of taboo to prove my point.
God,
I haven't been fuck like that since
grade school.
Would this line have had the same effect
if it was,
I haven't made love this intensely.
People may associate swearing with
somebody who's out of control,
swearing in rage.
But what's interesting in cinema is that
it can often be the opposite.
The person who swears is the one that's
actually in control of the scene.
Jerry [inaudible] guard in Fargo is
constantly sworn at by people he hires
and fucking wife,
you know,
or your fucking wife,
Cherry strangers through a bald face,
liar,
fucking liar and his own son.
And when he gets pushed too far,
he finally curses back.
But it's hilariously lane Darren
two-toned
port until yet he's an extremely weak
character who constantly gets pushed
around and the swear words reveal how
everyone in his life can talk down to
him and control him.
The one who swearing is the one
dominating the scene.
It's almost like a verbal way of marking
your territory.
You'll notice in the opening of
reservoir dogs that white is the only
one who gets this weird directly at the
boss showing not only that they have a
more casual relationship,
but that Mr. White is willing to stand
up to it.
My full time shit fucking here and y'all
give it back to you.
Swear words carry a lot of weight.
The most famous line in cinema,
right.
My hair,
I don't give a damn,
would not be the same without the swear.
A much bigger deal.
Back in 1939 the curse word really
embodies how fed up red is with scarlet
O'hara and he's not bubbling and anger.
It's pure apathy.
A place where swearing is controversial
is actually stand up comedy.
There's that angel debate of vulgarity
and whether or not comedians could be
just as funny without the constant f
bonds.
I have the glasses just completely
disguised as this guy.
And then it was something about
meantime,
two of them are stuck in a fucking cave
every week,
you know?
And that was the bit,
and then I said,
well,
let me see if it works without the word.
Right.
And I took the word out,
it didn't work.
And that's what bothered me.
And why do comedians swear?
But it's not about the swear word there.
It's about,
you know,
it's about you getting worked up.
Yeah,
it's about this guy is,
he means this.
He's so annoyed.
Right.
The fucking cave your ass funny.
That's contempt that take for example,
this swear word that's always bothered
me in the titanic,
he's got the iceberg warning and it's
fucking hand.
Excuse me,
his hand,
it serves no purpose and it's a poor use
of vulgarity.
Definitely makes anything funny.
It does.
There's no doubt about it.
Once you,
once you inject a fuck into your speech,
that makes it funnier.
It gives it,
it gives it an emphasis and it gives it
a shock.
Just about every swear word in the
departed seems to make me laugh.
Green is on a cup of coffee,
but spoke with anyone.
Just stop now go fuck yourself.
Kidding myself.
If sometimes a swear words purpose is
just as simple as that,
but in the movie they don't just swear
leftin write characters.
No when it's appropriate or not.
Like using a softer word when flirting
with someone.
Yeah,
just smack.
You'll have fun there.
I'll break your grades.
You've got her interest.
Then you can go in for the sweater.
When's the last time you checked before
I went to a second topic
is 40 Melissa McCarthy essentially
cameos as the character that swears
nonstop and it's just dumped.
Don't get me wrong,
I love a good improvised moment and
swear words can be really funny,
but this scene makes no sense in its
context.
Yo,
you're a horrible fucking woman.
This is why everybody hates you,
Jill.
This kind of shit.
I mean,
they're in a principal's office and they
just met and she's going to talk like
this.
It's not realistic and frankly it's
boring.
None of this talk is productive,
but how about this?
Let's try something a little more
complex.
What does this swear word accomplish?
Okay.
Tell me,
what did you mix say to hear multiple
migs and the next step is to do,
what did he say?
He said,
I can smell your content.
I see.
Misuse of swearing has many layers to
it.
At first it seems like a way to make
clarissa uncomfortable.
Hannibal obviously heard what makes that
and he just wants her to have to say it,
so she's embarrassed,
but with every insult and humiliating
comment he spits at her,
she stays strong.
Continuing to act polite,
insincere,
see a lot doc.
I think it's partly Hannibal's
admiration for her strength and a sense
of pity that causes him to help.
At the end of the scene,
there's a certain duality to swear
words.
On one hand they're funny,
but on the other hand,
they're deadly.
Nothing captures this idea more than
movies like full metal jacket and
whiplash where authority figures yellow
verbal abuse.
That's funny,
but also deeply manipulative and cruel.
What have we got here?
I'm fucking comedian.
I admire your honesty.
Hell,
I like you can come over to my house and
fuck my sister.
I know that's a lot of ways to use swear
words,
but what ties them all together is that
a swear word always reveal something.
It reveals control,
a relationship or even some
manipulation.
There's that saying sticks and stones
may break my bones,
but words will never hurt me.
After watching this video.
Do you still think that's true?
Maybe,
maybe not,
maybe fuck yourself
slightly trends,
just a bit of a break from the norm.
Just a little slot in the break.
The monotony of all that hard.